good morning john you and i grew up
going to racks
it was for the days when we'd been good
when wendy's wasn't good enough when it
was time
to split a cookie so soft and gooey that
you could push it back together and it
would stay that way
rax was a roast beef place like arby's
except that it was constantly undergoing
identity crises and it had no idea what
it wanted to be
mostly in their advertising they just
wanted to make the case that they
somehow
weren't like the other major fast food
chain here's one of the most successful
attempts to do that implying people are
oppressed because they can only get one
kind of chicken sandwich
at racks you can get an eenie meenie and
a mini
minnie and miney where's moe
no more oh they tried so hard to make
that work
many of their ads tried excluding
demographics to make it more appealing
to their core audience except that they
always then like
pushed back against it here's a good
example rax it's good for adults and
also
kids but only kids who act like they're
adults there are lots of bad racks ads
there's one where a phone eats a
sandwich which features yoga jones from
orange is the new black this one with
the giant chicken foot and then there's
one where a woman wants a pita pocket
with a meatball in it and she explodes
ads were bad in the 80s and 90s and
these are all your normal bad ad fair
but as racks continued to lose focus and
market share with an all-you-can-eat
pasta bar upgraded interiors
getting into pizza for some reason they
went all in
on the worst idea ever
mr delicious
hello i'm mr delicious the new spokesman
for racks restaurants
my job to encourage you to enjoy tasty
affordable meals in a more mature dining
environment he's like a low energy
rodney dangerfield he is a
sad man and that vacation he took to
bora bora with those two young
friends well that left mr delicious
feeling empty and unfulfilled now you
need to explain mr delicious just had
some rather delicate surgery
if there's no change he doesn't have to
squirm so much to put it back in his
pocket did we just hear about mr
delicious's vasectomy because his
analyst charges a lot to keep mr d's
hostility all
locked up wait what mr delicious always
carries this briefcase
mr d what's in the briefcase and all of
this is paired with the worst or
possibly best
tagline in all of fast food history
cracks you can eat here
i think there's an element of parody
here like you can eat here is definitely
a parody of a tagline mr delicious is a
parody of what a spokesperson is he's
not fun he's not happy he's not engaging
but they're also trying to
do a thing they're trying to identify
with a core audience but
who is that audience it's fast food
for grown-ups misogynist unfunny
alcoholic
sad grown-ups who gamble too much and go
to psychotherapy now the wonderful thing
here is we have a lot of
insight into mr delicious because the ad
agency and the management of racks
worked together
to create a mini documentary about how
successful mr delicious was
mr delicious speaks honestly to the
kinds of problems and issues that we all
face
i mean does he i don't feel like he does
who is the target market for this 15
minute mini duck
one assumes it was the rax franchisees
who were i'm sure
livid that the company was being
mismanaged so dramatically
yeah i go to the can during the
commercials but now that mr d is on i'll
just hold it mr delicious reminds me of
my dad
it's somewhat telling that the 15-minute
long pro mr delicious propaganda
documentary they put together included
this
line mr delicious is obnoxious oh my god
racks filed for bankruptcy less than a
year after the launch of mr delicious
making the confidence of this statement
absolutely
going to go down as one of the classic
characters in advertising history
seem just a little off the mark now rax
had a ton of problems and mr delicious
didn't cause all of them it was a
cutthroat time in the fast food industry
but whatever gamble these people decided
they had to make it went
even worse than mr d's trip to reno
john i'll see you tomorrow